were there any bonding exercises that
you guys did trust Falls or anything we
kind of I mean that's kind of what
wrestling
is the ironclaw is a true story about
the von Eric Brothers the biggest rock
stars in wrestling who ever come out of
Texas they were just Godlike all over
the world they were like
superheroes I think it's all about trust
when you have to learn a lot at once and
we were training with these professional
wrestlers and it was demanding because
you have to really commit to that fool
and like hitting them Matt over and over
and over again the last time I jumped up
so high over the ring and I'm looking at
him like this is going to suck remember
I hit super hard and I look up and I see
this guy he stands up and goes oh now
you're flying boy the support and true
love between the brothers I was really
special it didn't feel like any other
film I've ever worked on before Parris
Zach and I there's a Brotherhood
now